[Musique]
la france n'a pas voté depuis neuf ans
et depuis neuf ans bien des choses ont
changé
devant les panneaux riche de sens et
pauvres n'affiche pierre blanchard a
fait son choix et les bureaux de vote
malgré tout l'appareil solennelle du
tapis faire de l'isoloir et de l'urne
sont devenus très féminin puisque au
nombre des électeurs s'ajoute pour la
première fois la foule des électrices
au hasard des quartiers voici jeannois
tél impossible
[Musique]
et marie dubas sourire
madame joliot curie pour un seul instant
a quitté son laboratoire
voici la compagne d'un martyr de la
résistance est à propos net toute la
france avec conscience à voter parce que
le trocquer président du conseil
municipal la bonne religieuse
maurice thorez
un facteur
francisque gay
une gentille maman et c'est comme toute
l'armée le général ne votent pas voici
madame charles de gaulle
la quatrième république a dit le général
de gaulle sera une grande république
c'est ce sens que dégage des élections
qui marque le triomphe des idées de la
résistance anti fascisme et démocratie
[Musique]